[Music]
[Laughter]
now it's a [ __ ] rock Monday but I don't
know I'm a mess it's honey Holman no no
no huh it's honey hole Monday I I have a
very strong stomach I'm not okay I'm not
okay either [ __ ] Brendon Josh wolf
sent Brendon a video and then those
rendering videos ever seen I walk in you
were late and I said hey I gotta show
you something I was I didn't tip my hat
to let you now let's do it
you got got your 15 minutes right with
the terrible excuse traffic daddy had to
punish you and he goes come over here
and I sat down he goes now look at this
and there's a motorcycle guy and he's
he's about to jump is the guy stand this
as I see he jumps it cuts immediately to
what I don't what looks like wood or I
don't know pylons pieces of long pieces
of pylon and and then I see a like a
housing unit to housing it then of
course my eye adjusts and I realized
it's not wood it's a long arm it's too
long arms it's one got long into the
same guy it's one guy two euros and he's
got his arms all the ways things I even
I can't dude I'm on my stomach's alright
is elbow deep analysis but and then
don't say but here's the other thing
again this is my video Josh sent this so
disturbing ruined my day because the guy
alright
uh would you call it fisting for its it
was he's up to he's now he's elbow deep
in these its tongue and these Europeans
[ __ ] and that he grabs their
[ __ ] and pull yeah just tends their
rumps out they post their there if I
didn't know I didn't either it's the
sphincter mom if he has ever seen
tremors and it's just a giant they're
[ __ ] of like the rubber bugs like
coming out of their ass [ __ ] dude I'm
not only guys good I'm not okay I'm not
okay
I'd know to ruin your day it's honey
hole Monday honey hole that's not a
honey hole dude that's a honey hole
that's that's a dragon song that's
dragon tunnel Monday
they look like dragon tongues okay
there's one how the [ __ ] the level of
perversion and the level of depravity
human beings are willing to go to but
those guys the boys next step what seem
like they enjoyed it but what's after
that is it cannibalism I mean what is
the next we were like I want somebody to
chop his dick off eat it and then hit
the kill him I mean I don't know how I
mean the it so it looks it looked
dangerous when he was dry like you're
not mr. hands really guys can [ __ ] the
hours yeah I guess you wanna die yeah
but that was the same thing like this
guy was well you absorb you can absorb a
lot of things through the anus yeah you
could absorb off a suppository cocaine
you can drug out of here I'd eventually
just start putting in their anus out a
buddy who'd put whiskey in his butthole
how teenagers did that for a lot many
years about you put like half a shot of
them you blitz you absorb it right yeah
you can snort something you can you can
anally ingest it and you can nerve
orally ingested dangerous dude the whole
thing is bad dude it's what you get dude
for being late I had to punish you one
way that was the best way I do huh I
just go so dark when I see that stuff
I'm just like what is the world about
freaks dude what is it guys just dyin
got just gay boys take it to another cuz
dudes don't really have limits do they
cuz dudes don't let's be honest well
those guys you like to transfer saunas
of gay sex but dudes men are men the
only reasons showers exist is because of
women men wouldn't even clean themselves
I don't think they would Oh boys are
like I don't want to [ __ ] take a
shower
girls are like I need to be clean
they've actually proved that I know you
do cuz you know what it's like to be
clean but when you were younger you were
running around we came home you were
gonna jump in the shower when you're a
little boy you're like [ __ ] this it
doesn't mind it yeah don't fight it but
overall they're like no I can't give a
[ __ ] I mean one of the things about the
Mongols they used to talk about was that
they they never bathed Genghis Khan
because they were in the Gobi Desert so
they just they basically you know they
would treat their
clothing with with a sheep mutton oil
you know to make sure it was waterproof
and they they lived on curdled mares
milk blood from their horses and field
mice and grubs that they could catch
there's a really [ __ ] well they weren't
they just smell very it's not like [ __ ]
look like [ __ ] yeah they're like you
know and they lived on their horses and
they would write people non-stop yes
yeah yeah not not that mean nothing nice
we don't be like that
no I'm saying I'm saying we're like
society and you wash your [ __ ] to
sink yeah I clean my whistle are we
talking about I clean my whisk my
whistles calling Mongols then there's
brownie town yeah I need to be I need to
be clean enough to eat food off and let
that that honey hole yeah I want to I
wanted a sandwich at a place called the
honey hole yeah I think is the gay
district of Seattle really called ha
best sound ever had called the honey
hole the honey hole
you know the great name yeah because at
night it turns into a just a tall dude
oh the leather bar yeah
the bees are making some honey yeah boys
I don't know if I want lesson food in
the area where this dude I'm telling you
best sandwich I've ever honey hold on no
yet right there big boy Wow
they they do it right that looks good
that looks good good old gay sandwich OD
that [ __ ] is so nice ah hi sandwich in a
dick sucked honey hole yeah or just or a
plunge or just songs you know or an arm
plunge
oh god I wish we could play that video
for the faster now I don't they just so
they could get what we're referencing my
stomach actually flawed I've never been
right since god I don't know why
people's I don't like that [ __ ] don't
send me that stuff man I don't like that
disgusting stuff it's a hot chicks and
it oh if it's that disturber stuff don't
send somebody getting murdered don't
send we spent a lot of time on a chain
me you Eddie Bravo on Rogen if you want
we do yeah and any sense a lot of
conspiracy things and then what i do is
i bunk them and then and then Eddie
comes back what's up like a video we
shot Eddie side yeah you go I keep going
nice to meet you yeah you call me
government she'll go Eddie you egg him
on and then Eddie comes back with
something else and then Rogan will go
this is a very constructive thread
you guys are gonna get to the bottom of
this I'm sure this videos this is very
constructive and a good way to spend
your time this isn't a waste time at all
Rogan loves to find people to friends
who people we know who post
inspirational [ __ ] and all kinds of
stuff and you think definitely no
nonsense here I can't get enough of it
the train wrecks people on Instagram who
post inspirational [ __ ]
are almost always people I'm its
triggers for anybody he'd like the
successful stuff I hate all that
[ __ ] well cause it across the nation
because it's procrastination just weird
I got to get right before I go for what
I want I got to just get right anything
I don't know just just just get good at
something suck my honey hole yeah get
good at something I again I just don't
know how most people make a living
aren't they worried I was always worried
that I wasn't gonna be able to make
money so it just kept me on the straight
and narrow does that make sense like I
was just always like I don't have time
to do all this dumb [ __ ] like who's
who's got the life I want and now let me
try to do what they do
if the hurts that will take oh say if
they make you an option make them you're
history
Wow or me okay be ready to search me in
every person you meet oh this is uh just
a hashtags of inspirational quotes on
this rant these are girls that hey I'm
sorry she why are we why are you sorry
after so many years because today I saw
your pain in daughter's heart yeah you
wish she also made this up he didn't
read that oh wait without struggle there
is no progress oh thank god I'm ready
now when I'm having a tough day I can go
back to that and read it get the [ __ ]
out of here I like getting this stuff a
little imagination come on with massive
action goes a long way oh cool didn't
know that it's hard to be just friends
so when you fell in love
yeah I'm tell you I had an accent easy
to do this so so go to ask a question go
to ask question go ahead raise your hand
Brian hold on hold on
now now think about this do you already
know the answer oh he would do that to
you
do you feel like most people knew they
always know always yes you're about to
ask me a question is really complicated
yeah and one time I asked a question
teacher and I knew it's a bad question I
go I think the answer is it depends
right he goes very good yes sir
it depends it depends honey hole I went
no way I went to ask I went to another
acting teacher to get how many people
are lost in those acting classes well I
stayed in the acting class no 99 I have
a Honda I stayed in the acting last for
at least seven more years because I
can't tear myself away from a train
wreck my pretty fun Oh
dude II feel so painfully tacular
insanity that you see in an acting class
I knew a guy who who printed out a
manifesto and it said I am an artist and
it was his goals and he handed it out to
all of us and said I want all of you to
hold me accountable to these goals I am
an artist oh well I've never heard from
him since of course I don't like that
guy just disappears Jim that was that
was James Franco and he became a star
yes
no it was just did you get all these
crazies who would stop the class and get
up and make a declaration and say some
[ __ ] and then Anthony Hopkins came in I
think you need that because it's so
goddamn tough yeah you know so this well
I guess we have some times we haven't
we'd have well I was in a class for a
while with the biggest baddest
[ __ ] on the planet like Burt
Reynolds was in the class sometimes
[ __ ] Neil Simon innovative Broadway
royalty but um Anthony Hopkins walked in
one time cuz it friendly Anthony's
[ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah it was great cuz
you know in acting class it's like it's
religion acting class it's like and one
of those things away for free are they
no no no not not Oscars and he walks out
and somebody said I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit about silence to
Land's what it was doing and he went oh
yeah
so you just he became the character
right and so everybody was like so when
you prepare the research what are you
doing because I don't do any research
they go you know well okay but to
prepare how do you hold on about don't
do that I just I just assumed the
character and I just do it like he just
he just works on it I'll tell ya so tell
well technique goes a long way in acting
but he's also Jimmy's just a beef you
Southie he'd been doing it a long time
in so your ass gonna do miss Lee that
with talent yeah what's with you if they
have yes yes yes you have these guys who
come in and it's just like a whole
different thing like Burt Reynolds did a
scene in class you get like Burt
Reynolds or you get like who's a such a
the biggest movie started in the world
for ten years
I mean I've you know I mean just the
biggest [ __ ] but before that he
was no you should have seen an acting
class and we all went oh oh oh that's
why you're [ __ ] you're Burt Reynolds
I mean as good as it gets him slap that
reporter no yes yeah yeah watch that he
slept that [ __ ] dude yeah
oh he was the biggest stud for a little
biggest I do it there's legendary
football to legendary stories like him
in uh in Hollywood driving around with
the brownies and just chew oh yeah but
he played college football someone like
him that's his daughter
no no they were in a movie together she
was in Modern Family oh yeah then father
time says hey you're good lucks mm-hmm
yeah all the time dude father time
well Burt got a lot of work done and and
never took his coat is he was not just
dead dude yeah
friendly was such a stud have you I
wonder for you my to watch it cat that
documentary ways Tom out on Netflix
which one that Julia Julia Hernandez the
Gabriel Fernandez or something like that
oh yeah keep you heard about that what
about you you ever heard this story not
the little boy who was tortured by his
parents of murdered no and then they
kept beating the [ __ ] out of him and the
cops and the Protective Services kept on
there and the documentary baits how the
system failed this little boy I can't
watch it so it's crazy I can't watch it
either so please quit ask me if I seen
it here's what's crazy is a week after
that another little boy died in the same
County so it's like we have a problem
with the system dude that's not
surprising it's it's you mean I don't
want to deal with it you mean a state
government or federal government is so
anything with kids I can't watch my
harvesters well that's the worst thing I
can think of I want to just adopt him
it's horrible man I never watched that I
can't handle that at least a torture no
no I can't mom and dad torture I can't
until finally dead okay not for me man
why would they do that these [ __ ] six
months sometimes you're born into us
I hope he's but Dade there's been a
million [ __ ] there was a million [ __ ]
complaints when they checked on him and
the boy had bruises all over and then
they never acted on it they never did
anything and I see I think I don't know
the documentary but I remember the story
cuz happen in California I think the the
protective child service employees
actually went on trial they they were I
like to do because they didn't do their
due diligence and it's actually too much
for me to bear it's too much for me to
handle yeah it really is
we have children I can't talk about baby
momma's gone with Chicago she's back
today but pop was telling me yesterday
straight off the plane you got a deal
with a 14-week gold and a [ __ ]
four-year-old solo I said oh that's no
joke
that's a b-side the kangaroo pouch on
the front with the kid I'll play with
Tiger yeah up on both the bed yeah
please do Papa Papa I was live am ya
know the gonna feed dude it's a beast
that's a lot better see my kids were
older I Adam this weekend with that I'm
only you know different thing and my
daughter's 11 and she takes care of my
yeah well she becomes mom mm-hmm
I mean it's incredible we're in the
airport staff in hurry up what are you
doing you takin too long
put your bag on look both ways she just
kids I was in I was in Utah and then I
went to Omaha and then came back for
Friday so yeah then I came back to you
but she watches him on the slopes
everything because they were skiing they
weren't still oh you all got you but
she's like hold my pole she takes him up
to them she's just amazing
but that babies are no joke yeah babies
that's you had you had the five week old
and was thirteen weeks though thirteen
we call Abhijit no sense of time
four-year-old boy oh that's a lot alone
oh yeah
feeding him oh yeah waking him oh yeah
that's a lot full-time job
yeah beasty and how is that Tiger with
Boston
well loves him he's just he's four
sleaze rough with him yeah yeah but he
loves the [ __ ] got him he's a great big
brother
yeah some people get worried like I
think my family's where my brother's
gonna try and kill me
but Tiger loves them yeah he's yeah
super evil did he beat the [ __ ] out of
non-stop he did oh yeah non-stop when
you were younger not slow I don't see
him that good anger management it's so
bad I don't see him that way oh yeah
what would he do other now you could get
him going would you put you PO up or
anything you just I don't know just a
mad child and what's my parents got
sports got worse just we start taking
out on now I gave you a beat well just
ignore me you guys went to an all-black
school level predominately black school
yeah yeah a lot of black kids hmm hey
what J was violent super violent dude we
have our bet
remember this weekend in Israel out of
Sonya and I think Rogan is covering your
nut to be [ __ ]
I think Roman [ __ ] Rowling's Kevin your
bad pus is it - is it a live grant is it
five yeah no I would never bet you five
Greeks then you're not gonna pay no I
think we'd better find one I wanted more
ridiculous cause you're not gonna pay
five to grant I would pay I know you
were that's I think you say can I do a
layaway do we say two grand I do a
layaway I think we said two grand you
said you got it this morning I said too
bad on the show I think you said I'll
bet you $5,000 and then you went no not
five more I - I think grown went I'll
cover your - mm-hmm so here's where it
gets tricky Brian when saw better wins
who do I collect my money from because
it fits late
what that video that honey hole video
yeah no you what are you gonna do come
collect no you can't just do that to me
I wanted to come in with Crocs today
don't do it red eye I have a right to
thank you the honey hole no I have a
right to do it and I'm gonna do it I
think see what happens they do it dude
I'm gonna take those things I'm gonna
pin you down with pin you down alright
you try I'm gonna pin you down I try to
slap that honey hole around a little bit
slap my honey hole around cuz that's
where I really drop them and I'm gonna
slap your honey hold on a little bit I'm
gonna take those Crocs and there's a
dumpster out front i'ma throw them in
there don't you dare tell you don't wear
them dude listen to me right now you've
been warned the problem is you're
warning me then it's a free country and
I'm a man and I'll do what the [ __ ] I
want so I'll tell you what there's a
very good chance I'm gonna walk through
that door with Crocs and if you want to
come at me know this brother know this
brother don't call me brother listen up
bro listen brother know this I say this
as a man it's in your in your face I say
this program don't don't [ __ ] touch
my don't touch my hand like that again
dude you really come at his fist yeah in
your honey hole if you come at me just
like that
I say this to you and I say this to you
with it with a full heart and clear eyes
I'll meet you halfway
all right you got me halfway and you'll
be Shu and I might even meet you before
you get halfway so I said it all right
where you're crying
now if you say oh you better wear
understood don't wear my stage cuz I
mean I walk I'm gonna do your stupid
charity event on Wednesday you well
when's your stupid come to see me
Santino Bobby Lee Brendan Schaub Chris
D'Elia we're at the Laugh Factory show
starts at 9:45 Oh Late Show yeah Late
Show who all proceeds go to charity all
of what charities dude are two different
ones why - one is specifically children
another is something else yeah I'll tell
you about it I don't want to I don't
want to talk about it is it for oh
that's not good yeah it's it's bit hey
the money's going to wear it always
Holly give me yeah okay I'm buddy it's
for my whiskey
now your money yeah all right yeah it's
a teacher sent you know by the way I
know who made that is such a dick Martin
make that I yeah I call him up and I go
I'm can you do my thing and he goes say
I have the number two podcast with Bobby
Lee say it the number two it was it
number two for a second oh my hair could
be better in that [ __ ] painting
picture yeah my by the way I'm getting
my hair done today by my my hair stylist
Patrick and he goes um I go I think I
need a hair transplant I another one and
he goes I have the guy can you imagine
if I walk in here without lids and a
[ __ ] full editor no dude j/mol night
game [ __ ] why not why not look great
game over
they gotta take one about who died said
he has the guy to do it
this guy's good where did Theo - Theo
has a [ __ ] mullet dude Theo von he
got a hair transplant
yeah multiple times right why like this
is safe oh yeah yeah really it's the
show one day doing it yet blood
you had like stubborn boy wait so I
didn't know I thought
so I'm sorry that's not natural he has a
full head of hair at least not the all
no no he says it you think I feel like
maybe Anthony took something from the
back huh right he was before it even
becomes a problem he's out of his mind
he wasn't losing his hair I don't know
I've never seen your CEO think it might
be a wig is I don't know get into the
head I have no idea that might be a wig
I don't it's fall it's the same thing
every time it's never changed when does
it bring him up let me look who's here
mm-hmm I don't think so though that's an
old clip though a hair transplant he
talks about it obviously yeah yeah I'm
not say anything he hasn't put out there
huh
we get it it's really always the same
it's got white hair - I'm saying but
yeah it's very very like unique I mean
you got it done not unique what's the
word here looks good
organized yeah he has a strong hairline
yeah but where would where would you go
to get it done
yeah you got a different dog
[ __ ] these days right oh yeah is it that
I take they take they don't cut a piece
out they take strand out of here they
take the follicle here and just put it
here they do follicle follow my wall
I've been doing that for everything no
they used to take us they take a strange
sound like it cut a piece out under a
microscope didn't they take it out now
they just do it from here so you know
I'm seeing by doing a Papa I don't know
you just get a wig I won't get a wig cuz
I can yank on it but I wouldn't mind
getting uh but this is a problem I can't
be fifty to be doing all this dumb [ __ ]
just to fix your here though well I'm an
old man there so we're the oldest
thought oh this is the oldest there
I mean buys the promises when I shave
it's not a good look
make sure the gold are huh yeah alright
are you still shooting a [ __ ] show
three more episodes buddy boy three more
episodes
is there a bit mad yeah that's a great
picture right that's a great job that's
such a cool jacket I know I can't buy
one of those actually I want to wear it
oh yeah hey Chris send us your [ __ ]
jackets where we beat you up before you
get too upset [ __ ] well let's see how
answers I think would be Crispin lifted
into place thick - oh my god right now
with his weight dude I don't know why
you just don't get your hair done before
it's too late cuz what you don't like
it's isn't a hims commercial won't you
do it won't you realize it's gone it's
too late I know that's good right there
yeah
[Music]
sometimes I call him he doesn't pick up
and I just got a text it says makes me
so mad yeah but you gotta get your hair
done dude um a honey hole get off your
[ __ ] phone
Whitney Cummings yeah chair dude yeah
better like yours dude it's gonna be
stupid I don't want a low cost hair
plant I want the best hair to do do you
think I need to go in there no I'm not
gonna [ __ ] found you all that that's
not cool dude
and it has to be a really good hair look
that could be you like you leave that
you're top left yours a little worse
let's be honest and then look at his on
the bottom mm-hmm guy on the right Jesus
that's amazing
what from dictates that mister steal
your girl yes oh that's him
celebrity hairstylist wait wow I'm not
letting that guy touch my foot that guy
knows maybe - don't touch me he looks
good weird sanity's it's got eyes lips
it's the whole thing's a weird you know
plan G we do this Chester dudes with
beads and there's a lot off I don't
trust guys with beads I don't even got a
guy where buy just [ __ ] weird I agree
with you who that's transgender look at
him who's transgender well ok services
what can you do a file if I'm a
transgender oh my god Oh interesting
Wow unbelievable okay well I don't
anybody who's that much of a marketer I
don't know
well you separate yourself I now are
they good artists can't I'm just a
director to experience this for huh
let's do it before it's too late though
let's just see how it goes I'll bring
you in and when they gonna clone here
come on I've been waiting see how far
away they are from [ __ ] cloning hair
always look what the Piven did probably
a hair transplant I mean probably
traditionalism has to be that one of the
best used to play you know you splay
George Costanza on Seinfeld you still
Walt yeah huh yeah
we're using stem cells were first
baldness and it's actually well let's go
yeah baldness man it's tough in it I
mean yeah it's annoying soon there will
be unlimited hair new use of stem cells
and 3d printing could make baldness of
obsolete for the wealthy all right well
I make money and I would spend I'd spent
a lot of money for a good full head of
hair how much would I spent I spent a
lot of money
what like what like bees serious hama
grant yeah yeah it's fair right here I'd
spent a hug gotta keep my head right I
just
that's the number hundo [ __ ] god I have
to do it that's the whole sentence never
doing 100% I know you know what [ __ ] it
yeah that make payment I have great hair
put me on a layaway [ __ ] off 100% mm-hmm
honey good I'm gonna well how much we
spend and get a bigger dick what's that
how much you guys spend to get a bigger
[ __ ] Oh God
God I mean you know and I I do fine
thank God but yeah you're good I see
where you were I'm good too I'm just
saying if there I came in a little more
girth if you've got a small Willie you
spent all your money at watch this
if so watch all your money all the money
you would go bankrupt so so so so here
you go Jeff Bezos lead out houses you
sell everything you buy everything and
then you and then you just make money
back just duck but all the money all the
money cloning a dick you know you know
that the way they do it now is not over
that now it's but some people have a
micropenis there's a guy I know who's a
very handsome large man and a friend of
my had sex with him and she said he's
got a baby dick and I don't please don't
tell me that out loud I didn't want to
hear out a baby dick you got a baby dick
is so amazing I know yeah peace
enlargement surgery now it's a nightmare
do they they just snip like the hood
like extends just a little bit but it's
not good yeah they cut a tendon it off
and get the [ __ ] out of here out no
that's the way for 5 to 10 grand say no
it's not good got some doctor come up
with a procedure to left
lengthen your dick yeah so risk give it
a big old angry some girth with a big
ridge down the middle yeah yeah you put
that big fat vein and just so he just
standing up 10 hot just all right you
want him bent backward you want him to
say hey don't do it dad let's do a
downward dog yeah like dude relax your
back bro you bet you're bending your
back what are you doing are you looking
at the sky yeah like if a hair
yes see how my voice changed a little
bit make a load now make a hole with
your mouth yeah I want to do dick
yeah you see how I'm straining yeah yeah
there it is what are they doing here so
that goes yeah that does that pushes
your dick out and then also makes the
thicker that very oh wow that's very
well you know bad [ __ ] her yeah no
thanks no thanks Gary has a pretty good
sized dick what's he doing you know
worried about the skid yeah I don't know
I wonder if I don't know all of that
stuff this one's fda-approved this is
all coming this is all coming man
it's all of it it's like women being on
a probe larger breasts all that stuff
but I think we're always away you think
I do
I don't think science is too worried
about it like what do you forget you
deal there's so much money in a crowd of
i but there's so much money on it
doesn't right do you how about corona
starting to pop off a little bit is it
is it is it a little bit of us it was a
statewide uh emergency in Washington
when I was there like well I'm out of
here
but it's hiked and I still went to the
gun look dumb wall what oh it's all so
hype I took six planes over the week six
planes I'm sure other people are okay
but they said it is gonna be a problem
really I'm not like a compromised immune
system and then I found out that the
meant the people who were collapsing in
China were men over 60 and there were
heavy smokers with diminished lung
capacity yeah you know that people
that's like six people died right now in
Washington they just went up to six but
do we know how how old they were I don't
know the ages era they were Asian they
were Chinese from China I think but
they're both they're from China but
they're Americans and they were there
were 70 or 80 years old and they're know
what the one dinner Irvine they it was
like old person's home yeah and like the
old lady got it but then one of her
Wright family motors traveled from China
yeah I mean so you know she was let's
some dog got it children what and then
they say that the facts don't do [ __ ]
I'm asking that's just all the fire they
don't do it yeah oh there you go - and
their 80s one in their 70s okay so
that's father time ducky I easier this
on the fluid
yeah
so you know pick your picker police it
like either we're gonna get you a tease
yeah yeah bigger bigger issues these
things these things happen when you when
you flout when you flout agricultural
laws when you when you have wild animal
markets and those viruses mutate like in
China or China was trying to create a
chemical weapon of warfare
well the weapon that was like a German
doubt like oh wow a germ warfare they
have is really really rough [ __ ] but
that that's how they think that they
think that's gonna be the biggest
problem in a few years though the
disease warfare where they've release a
virus yeah and then we can't figure it
out hey when you think about even it now
that right this is a dark podcast what
though just saying even if it took out
you know 10 million people still be
awful yeah world keeps more less traffic
is that we're trying to save less
traffic well in Ellie engine more
beachfront property yeah you know yeah
that's why I used to do a joke about
that which is they're just an indictment
on human beings if a billion people die
to be horrible but if it was no one you
knew and they were way over there you
wouldn't miss work over it oh that's
going on minutes every day and they're
it's such a shame it's true yeah what'd
you do this weekend I think I was
depressing as me this weekend the only
thing I can really remember is getting
fake nails and they hurt like oh I love
your nails I told you I liked them well
the thing is that it takes some
adjustment so it feels weird cuz they're
so long and then on top of that I need
to be careful when I do certain things I
put on my shoes because if like my
finger slips like the nail bends over so
it's just a lot of my adjusting but your
hands look good thanks I like them too
yeah they're cute yeah yeah they look
good it's funny how women have to just
do do do so many things oh you like
paint their face every morning every
morning they clash your face
I'm not a makeup day like makeup I'm not
a makeup guy you don't wear a ton of
makeup I only fill in my brows and put
on mascara I can't be bothered you have
the right skins you have amazing skin
agent did you ever think about doing the
eyebrow thing no I'm so sorry enough I
drilled
a lot of needles next to my face well I
don't know why you're doing this
I saw so enjoy yo why you do I like your
eyebrows yeah you don't need to do this
why don't you take NIH's like dude cuz i
don't have to worry about Oh what do
they what did they do but they [ __ ]
scrape their eyebrows so they state so
like so you don't put makeup on it
permanently States for a year wait go
back its skull scraping it's a micro
bleeding oh dude
so it's basically like a year-long
tattoo that lasts on your face so you
just always look like your browser done
damn
oh wait I don't get why you're doing
this I have I think I read your eyebrow
yeah yeah you know my my ex swore that
you got your brows done I was like I'm
like I woke up like those are perfect
eyebrows there are usually good yeah
yeah you can browse like they've been
plucked I know that's [ __ ] astonishing
it's weird you have people think that
how much do you spend on them a month
yeah but yeah my girl it looks and it
was she was like this OH
like why I don't why are you doing this
vanity everybody does things you got a
man I like your eyebrows well so you see
people in the gym who spend two hours in
the gym killing themselves they look
good but it's a lot of work like that
that aerosol bike that you do I mean
it's so [ __ ] hard it's so good for
you but Jesus how about something at the
meet and greet this lady this girls who
smoke the good-looking girl put it that
way she goes don't listen to your
friends I like that you're a little
thick and fat you know I'm the other I
got you thank you well girls do yeah I
went now I got to thank you ruined the
night
stirred left point you ruined my night
be good girls love they don't they don't
give a [ __ ] about being no girl is ever
in the history of the world gonna go
Brendan was so into her when it was 260
not 275
they could give a [ __ ] no it's already I
know I'm on that carnivore diet Corona
diet it was like working out with Deion
Sanders I'm Deion Jordan unless you
worked out deal yeah with dion jordan
and he's bigger than you I mean I mean
Jesus Christ and just like dude well
this is NFL talk so people are gonna
zone out but there's a linebacker for
Clemson who won the buckets weren't I
think twice like junior and senior year
or whatever did one of two years around
so that makes him the best line back on
the planet
he's like tall and lanky he ran a 4-3 in
the 40 as a linebacker what
yeah and they go up to him they go to
him I love us they go hey so you know
you're kind of a tweener cuz you're kind
of tall and skinny for outside
linebacker and then can't be a 3/4 down
and they go what position you play and
he looks at the camera goes defense and
walks away
Oh draft that man is the first he saw
three nine Isaiah simmons-howe Ozzy
6-foot 3 240 pounds oh my [ __ ] god so
he's not lanky it's not like well for a
linebacker he is at 240 yeah look at his
builds like long he's just haul like
that's a tall one might be talking six
four look at his [ __ ] arms see but
he's real skinny 6-3 6-4 to 38 and then
they interview him and because you know
you know they had a foul though he's
like you know you're not really a middle
linebacker you know I'll stop safety
you're kind of and they go what position
you loose cameras you tell he's like
good boy behind that he's kind of
knowing his defense and walks away and I
was just like drop 30 Mitch I'm you
Sarge a baller such a ball oh wait he
played for Clemson yeah yeah this is the
best lawyer best player
Christ I cannot get enough I can't get
enough for the deep of combine oh I
watch all of it I need to watch it I
think I'm over that kind of [ __ ] you
know I think you know a lot of it's
weird too because for a lot of these
kids it doesn't really matter
they're sure like he didn't like he's
gonna get picked in the top five but
it's like you know he's just a freak
he's just a freak
oh well it's like the the best player
like borough the quarterback for LSU and
I like when guys pull this they're like
oh no I'm not gonna do it you've seen my
tape I don't need to jump through all
these [ __ ] loops and holes for you
guys I'm the best player in the country
you know I'm not gonna do this stuff it
doesn't do it I love that I'm not gonna
do the combines no no like I'm what no
they can only hurt my stock you saw me
play I bawled out this year you watch
the film says smart but then there's
some guys like this sighs this you he'd
been top-10 pick prey anyway but now I
mean I'm I'm taking them I'm taking
number one then there's also the kid
from Ohio State the DN who's that
absolute freak and asked them do the
commbuys it's not the best player in the
nation I'm good you guys know this look
at the table the such ballers did well
when you're under like 1920 you've also
been stronger and faster and they're
better than everybody your whole life
until they get there till they get there
again NFL goes hey buddy
grown man yeah go man well there are a
lot of grown men that can't wait they're
not hearing a peep out of this Isiah
Simmons though you know you got a
problem with yes you got a problem on
your hands
oh just a freak you solve look at his
body dude look at this to me the way
he's built those combines are so fun to
watch
well of course they're look at this
that's Lamar Jackson who's that oh he's
a he's a cornerback from a house state
such a stud just freaky
all of her freaky there's some oh he's
so good there's a second Christian
Fulton there's a offensive lineman who
ran like the fastest he's like 360
pounds around like some like four nine
and there's like what the [ __ ] it's like
what what is going on I mean just guys
getting bigger more
was the threader naturally fast they
train differently they trained from a
young age yeah that that is a except as
I'm telling you man so I would take him
number one
just cuz defense is more important in
some ways well you need a quarterback
but yeah quarterback and we think the
kid from again everybody's known about
the kid from alabama TOA who hurt his
hip and had to have surgery on his hip
and missed the game he's he's it's so
important for him to do well in this
because he'd been the first pick in the
draft but he blew his [ __ ] hip out
like bo Jackson did is he Samoan or
something yeah what gave that away to a
two Silvassa or the or the wide no to a
taco Valley or Tonga baila what's he
play what position quarterback for
Alabama won the national championship he
was the I who Jalen Hertz was a starter
was it playing well and at the half h
they made he was a freshman he came in
and won the game for him and he was a
starter for this the year so good who
what is the hardest position to play on
the quarter best so defense yeah
cornerback corner corner oh yeah that's
what I get paid so much yeah I mean it's
really not good yeah not my Macker no
corner it's such a tough job so much
pressure there's such but I mean I think
the toughest job in sports is
quarterback hands down I created you
meet quarterbacks are in the world now
name the good one I mean come it's so
tough I mean they draft guys call the
times but all this money to put all his
resources so difficult having to read a
back feel that quickly all the stuff
they have to do all the stuff to a FAFSA
see that kid at the bottom he looks kind
of like Stewie
if Griff he grew up yeah far left he's
that he's gonna be the number one pick
in the draft for the bangles he's super
cocky quarterback quarterback well
here's what since throughout him then
we'll move on from football Joe burrow
so before he had the season like this
season last season's good before that
they use a transfer for I think Ohio
State but he wasn't even projected be of
traffic there I kill he'll be like maybe
he'll be on stricted free agent and then
balls out now he's the number one pick
and he's so err getting cocky which I
dig is a quarterback hmm he's so he just
he's just what just I got like after he
they beat LSU be--i'll Oklahoma
there you go well you have one more game
against Clemson how do you think we're
doing yes excuse me how can you do this
well we've already won yeah we know
we'll be fine and she's like well
they're really good II think we'll be
fine and then balls out yeah you kind of
had that go that's good nobody signed
with LSU they go how do you feel you
slob football there what do you mean is
I am football a superhero yeah but did
Johnny football ever this Manziel he's
just disappeared
no just disappeared yeah that worked out
for me did that even make was like but
that's amazing a colossal tragedy I just
feel like your whole life is there he's
so good in college Texas A&M he was so
good and he just in just white it just
disappeared that if that's just a
different animal man it's hard to you
know you know but I mean you got a
really especially beat his size you've
really gotta buckle down and know the
game and can't rely on just athleticism
and he's Johnny Manziel as athletic is a
Lamar Jackson no right so then you get
there and you know you're not the fast
guy in the field you get that line back
around a 4-3 oh really get a run now no
you can't you know you're not and then
you got the smartest minds in the game
picking up your tendencies and they make
you do what you're not good at
so think I get that's what I that I
never never smartest in the game I
finally bad to his right so what all
we're gonna do all game is his put his
his success rate when he rolls out right
it's 40% well we'll take those odds so
we're just gonna make him roll out to
the right until he gets good at rolling
to the right yeah I love that I just and
that's what I find fascinating and it's
like exactly like my Tyson Fury saying
and figuring out in the 12th round he
can't find on his back foot so I'm gonna
push him so they don't but then he went
to a coach went let's come up with a
game plan to force him on his back foot
no he did I didn't know that okay so his
old coach Oh Tyson Fury up Ben Davidson
who's a young guy Hawkins Krunk Jim who
that's what they do
yeah they study the film leo well this
is what you got to do you got to move
him back so it wasn't him he came out
with it was his I was just eating well
he has the skills to do short reinforce
the game plan yes sir he said put on
weight and just [ __ ] barrel here's
what you got to do Wow you know they
just announced the road
yes but now now Wilder has to figure out
go don't go to a coach and say I teach
me how to fight I'm not going to he
thinks his coach is fine he was thinking
about firing the coach I threw in the
towel for that's a bad idea
horeb I did yeah Wow I know huh dude
when style better beats Romero I want
cash I'm gonna punch in your [ __ ]
honey hole do well I'm sitting on my
honey oh yeah there what my honey hole
won't be there my footwork stupid now
doesn't matter what do you mean doesn't
matter what it doesn't do to have my
[ __ ] cash I will have your cash you
have my cash because uol is pissed and
your well is tired of not winning
championships you see the way do you see
him break dancing no let me see that
Yoel knows that he has one shot at this
style bender is awesome and he is the
future of the sport and I love him to
stop ever has more experience right in
kickboxing nope MMA - is more fight
that's not true not in the FC bubble I'm
saying MMA overall record is more ok not
I don't believe that's true but it might
be please check on that for me chin ok
wait which one either way MMA fights
golden style better as Sabah nur is a is
a tall
you know you girls Zhang's fighting to
you wanna look at these two bad
[ __ ] gonna be good that's for
today started dancing so I have here
Brian
good girl said hoodie sit down
never saw better ask for this fight
you'd have to grant yo Romero title shot
he asked for it because he wanted to
prove that he can take out the best
wrestler but stop it what got a bloody
great stop better used to be in a dance
group so he said I used to be one I said
yeah him and his boys
that's why wouldn't you rare when he
came out against Whitaker who knew his
boys were dancing that was his old group
get you out of there
backflip come on go let me see that
again [ __ ] this
you don't think he's gonna win now bro
no no when you can do a backflip now
hold on I need to be shitty cuz fans
like god dammit Brendan it's happened a
month ago so did have a month to go
honey hole on on I like the way he's
moving
Oh what the [ __ ] even though he's behind
him in jeans fine you gotta love that
[ __ ] rug both times forty well
you know might be eighty
no he is a just a freak did he say I'm
Rogan he goes look walk down the street
of Gilbert there everybody look like
media what a freak I'm excited for that
fight
wow you style banner is you're right he
is a giant cat he's taller me taller
than you hold me look at the food truck
tire dollar me man I was like you shot a
[ __ ] dude yeah he's so talented
well I I haven't seen him really getting
hit well now that's not true Kelvin
Kelvin hit him know that now beat down
Wadi Kelvin I hit him he played that
game because you don't want to make your
wars okay let's do help I'll meet you
here is that right prove a point yeah oh
did she Whitaker hit him at all no I did
not help I did not almost billion views
I think and I think I can validate with
numbers you the biggest star the UFC has
right now so was he well he's calling me
if we go back-to-back he's gone oh I saw
it I saw the picture he's a big kid
what's your way there do you have any
idea
how'd you ask him that yeah he's broad
he's thin fan he probably weighs 200
pounds right there more than that I
think he said was like to Ted or
something because he was like there we
talk about heavy weight you think I
could easily do it man yeah and you too
dude yeah one of my faves he's talking
you right there about yeah I'm telling
you look at that look at that look at
the bricks look at the bricks huh yep
Wow you got a helmet of hair there don't
you we're in Spain are you from I can
everywhere in Spain you fries you're not
American I know do your Spanish as it
gets - what if I could translate dress
that might some of my here on yours
I would I would like that I'd let you
honey homie for that we'll get some
kurta bats dudes yes sir
okay just an update how much huge day
yeah good good
sometimes need a professional to talk to
him that's how it is
sometimes you got problems your friends
can't help you you need a licensed
counselor a licensed professional did
you talk about better help he can start
communicating under 24 hours it's not a
Christ slants not self-help we're
talking professional counseling done
securely online from your phone laptop
they have clients worldwide log on your
account anytime send a message your
counselor what if you want you timely
thoughtful responses you can schedule
weekly videos phone sessions whatever
you want they got you
there's no uncomfortable waiting rooms
like traditional therapy forget about
it's also affordable yeah it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and get this financial aid is
available Wow
better help want you to start living a
happier life today visit their website
and read their testimonials all right
these are better visit visit visit our
help calm /ki D that's better help h ELP
and join over 700,000 people taking
charge of their mental health there's a
special offer for you guys you get temps
off your first month at better help calm
slash kid oh oh man dude oh I used this
product not less than two days ago oh
dude hell yeah my balls look like Jeff
Bezos had dude my balls are so smooth
right now
bro I'm smooth operate my whole my whole
area my whole area down there has a
shaft a shaft couldn't look better
my whole area has been scape oh my god
better
I like having less hair down there dude
that's cos using manscape the electric
trimmer their lawnmower 3.0 they're new
they do new the skin-safe technology so
won't snag or nichkhun don't want an S
mag you're nuts
so do you don't do any of them well they
redesign the electric trimmer it has
proprietary skin-safe technology so it
will not Nick or snag your knots what
I'm saying dude and hey don't use the
same trim that they use on your face as
you do your balls you know most guys do
you know most problem I don't care but
some guys do you know use manscape
manscape also has a crop preserver anti
chafing ball deodorant and moisturizer
alright get 20% off and free shipping
with the code fighter at manscape calm
and by the way they won't tell you this
but on the manscape shaver they got a
little light the light that lights up
your areas your nether so if you want to
go down the buddy hole oh yeah if you
want to go down your honey hole screw up
the honey hole trim it up a little bit
up for your man take a look or your girl
that's all manscape calm
code is fighter that's 20% off and free
shipping with manscape comm code is
fighter great unveils mm-hmm just a
little update with him
they raised four hundred and seventy
four thousand dollars for cuida and he
and his family have actually chosen not
to go to Disneyland and keep the money
they're actually donating all of it to
two different foundations they're gonna
donate to dwarfism awareness Australia
and ballooning healing foundation okay
now I have a call I want to go dissin it
I think that was the initial thing that
the comedian Brad Brad knows yeah yeah
he originally wanted to raise money to
send him there but the little boy and
his family thought it'd be better to use
the money to help others now dwarfing
dwarfism awareness
I just don't think that's the big short
side of the money I just think there
might be something better
how about take a bunch of kids who are
sick or whoever might be dwarfs whatever
they are and let's get them to go to
Disneyland bring all of them to
Disneyland do they get a solve anything
no but it would be fun for them but I
don't know if dwarfism awareness maybe
just bullying in general but even
bullies bully in this so how do you how
does it cost money to create awareness
on dwarfism or bullying like what do you
mean by that
isn't there a better way to spend the
money on something that knows maybe like
really useful like what's the charity
we're doing one thing's for what
dwarf ISM awareness is started by
somebody with good intentions and stuff
but I just whenever I hear that stuff I
always go III always just can't help but
to say there's got to be a better way to
do it well now if you're a dwarf yeah
but you hope you know what you can do
you can have billboards and say did you
know that there are 200 different types
of dwarfism which is there
huzi and we're admitted go back to
[ __ ] down there all right it says yeah
queue on the word [ __ ] is considered
offensive it is considered most
offensive when misused to describe those
with dwarfism except words use our dwarf
little person says person with dwarfism
short stature but most would like to be
called by their name rather than I've
done other day he it's the same me like
if there's a like let's say the four of
us are hanging out in a group and so
much pie and like how'd you hear what
that dude said like which one they turn
out like the giant asian guy yeah like
that's not rude or if there was so many
black but why did black but why didn't
somebody decide [ __ ] was was
derogatory and not being a dwarf because
would like like dwarf is I do do you
know it almost sounds condescending and
worse than like something out of one
human to a [ __ ] like I always say he's
a mental [ __ ] he's got a small brain
so I like that but we're gonna [ __ ] it
why are you taking all these words Oh
I don't want ever I would never insult
somebody Brett Williams is a friend of
mine when they were [ __ ] making fun
of the [ __ ] though well no I would
never call I called rabble rouser let's
go they're going I call him Brad did you
know I never would even you know I don't
think of them that way Hamid I feel like
like I feel like dwarf is offensive yo
it doesn't matter cannot a dwarf so but
yeah that's what they'll be called let's
do it
I wouldn't throw in the dwarf either
worse I feel dwarf is like a troll troll
connotation of yeah obviously
no but role is not acceptable in this
[ __ ] cover sex know what I'm saying
like I always bring a troll problem no
I'm trying to solve the problem
obviously we need to work for some
awareness I stand corrected but is it
because guys like this aren't aware that
is troll this fat [ __ ] I'm aware I think
it's very offensive but I'm saying dwarf
and troll seem like the same thing give
your money to morph under the bridge
same as trolling no nobody has ever said
dwarf under a bridge you trolls bad
because Rawls patrols our monster has
recognized this look up troll and look
of a picture of it's an elliptical yeah
its mythical it's like damages well
there you go
mythical cave-dwelling but then there's
also tomato cave dwelling being ooh
depict in folklore is either a giant
orator if we're having a very ugly
appearance okay so we know that to
patrol is not in this conversation but
there's also the movie trolls like see
they're cute yeah see that's cute well
yeah yeah patrols yeah I thought yeah I
don't know nice to talk to a dwarf about
it I feel like the wharf is also not I
say little person I say but I just call
by the first name but I put little
yeah now you can do a little Dave nah
little red little Dave a little little
be ya little Bob Big Bob small Bob
Mexican Bob
yeah that's how we do it man it's not
offensive ah like old Brian know why but
know what else we got at school they
raced all that money when are you giving
it back it was a goth kids a fraud I was
like get the [ __ ] out of here so it's a
bummer somebody's looking for attention
yeah so just an update with Steven
Spielberg's adopted daughter Mikayla
over the weekend she was actually
arrested very early in the morning for a
domestic abuse charge and her husband
came out that's her husband he is a
professional darts player and he
actually came out and said that it was
just a misunderstanding
nobody knows what the domestic abuse
charge was exactly for we just know that
she was arrested at 6:00 a.m. I believe
it was Saturday she was hitting him or
he throwing darts at her uh
it does not say but she was the one
arrested she was later bailed out a we
got sure she's embark on a new doing
porn yeah what about her um few stops
her porno out hmm
I don't think it's out yeah she just
announced that she was gonna be doing
porn if you're Steven Spielberg like
[ __ ] or if he just text her
[ __ ] I feel yeah come on man et I can't
put up with this [ __ ] yeah the whole
thing's a disaster though so maybe she's
you know maybe he was always on set
doing [ __ ] jobs or some [ __ ] the
whole thing's nuts well she was a book
or nothing it's about the cave maybe
look man I would check the porno out
just you know give her views uh I would
not but she's doing it Rosen's playing
darts and darts player that's not
covering the bills I don't know I don't
I don't think that's necessarily why
she's doing it I think she's good with
money
come on man
she's got a bad though yeah Wow
gets an ass on her look how happy she
got miserable she is on the red carpet
that's her down we got that one is that
the evidence you know where it just goes
well yeah what can you do man
guess she's not happy hi yeah
no did he adopt got her husband it's
just brutal did for me I am he's got
that cool sweater go back I don't want
to be a day old is she she is 23 yeah
she's young
yeah it's not just lost and strange
thing that's I believe she's also the
youngest one out of his seven children
she's the only one adopted oh [ __ ] yes
yes I see his six weeks oh he has his
current wife had two kids from a
previous relationship he had one and
they both have two children together
yeah and then they adopted her so they
have seven kids in a week so mad so it's
all different now though her face I mean
this is just somebody who's looking she
wants to be seen I heard I don't know
who knows hey Steven put her in [ __ ] you
know peace whoo the whole thing is it's
not bad looking know who knows what this
is I mean it's a I don't know look I
know like this I don't think you're
Steven Spielberg yeah are we doing
wait what are you doing this that's his
daughter
his wife or something like well that's
Kate Capshaw's night as well okay Kate
Capshaw's what that's his daughter
if you're him you're psyched about the
[ __ ] yeah heartbreaking
what else you got it's her body though
you know I'm so glad you did it okay so
there have been reports that Mike Tyson
is willing to pay someone and it doesn't
specify whether it's a man or a woman
but someone ten million dollar
ten million dollars to marry his eldest
daughter
I eat ICICI think I heard that fake but
I heard that like that got around and
then I this is the Michael Blackson
thing yes
then Michael blacks is the one who like
breath go ahead with the comedian
Michael but you know that is not
hilarious but so you see that obviously
she's a full-figured woman yes plus plus
a carry on will know is that his wife is
that my wife that's who he's with right
now I'm not sure if he's married but
they're together yeah the whole story is
that he is trying to help his daughter
look for love right now
there was something with Michael
Blackson we all have the waiter blacks
earthy so there's like a little bit
about oh my god go to that's the story
he's a funny I go black market joke
niacin went Adam because he wrote a
letter to he wrote a DM e DM Mike Tyson
I'm a knock the black coffee we go to
this gym this is the best this is the
best part of the [ __ ] story so he DM
sir
do they have where it's at if this is
true I think I finally later settle down
oh no you gotta you gotta find good
typing Michael Blackson i DM to Michael
Michael that's so great look it just
said it because listen you black [ __ ]
no no no no no no that's the response
you got to get Mike relaxin ceases DMS
the real Mike Tyson you can say I'll
marry your daughter and Mike goes that
it's a funny DM but I don't what the
[ __ ] he's thinking oh here it is so yo
this is Michael Blackson taught DM in
Mike Tyson about 10 million agios if
this is true I think I'm ready I'm ready
to settle down I know I've been dipping
and dabbing a few snow bunnies in Asian
persuasion but I'm ready for your
beautiful Queen I'm ready to give you
some grandkids that will have the
complexion of Tyson Bedford knowledge of
Cicely Tyson talk to you like Mike Tyson
hopefully not built like Tyson Fury I
really don't give a [ __ ] about the money
but I'll take it waiting to hear from
your father-in-law sir so that Mike
Tyson sees it goes it's listen you black
a little [ __ ] Lissie black a little
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] ain't real and soon as I find
the person s started to meme I'm gonna
knock him the [ __ ] out so make sure it
ain't you burnt roach looking [ __ ]
my daughter's happily
oh it's my daughter's happily in a
relationship with a nice-looking man so
she's not interested in an overcooked
hot dog like you next time you do my
podcast I'm gonna knock the black off
mode it might take a year because you
black as [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of my DM
before I get your black ass too poor you
know yeah you know that huh
no oh my god so here hit me the Alfred
ten million to get his daughter's just
it's just fake it's just rolling and
then Michael Blackson saw that and DM
the real Mike Tyson that's unlike this
wants to fight a lot but I like Michael
Michael Blackson response oh my god what
the [ __ ] am i sorry please don't hit me
I'm just a beach beach ass that that's
from that's from Friday oh he put it
kicked on Friday huh
fine you didn't think he was great spawn
back I feel like that's a lot of people
they don't like you there Sean make fun
of people and then they don't realize
that they actually see that like oh [ __ ]
my passion just got Street could he not
could you think he could knock out be
less white I'm straight as [ __ ] Oh what
else you got you a bitter sad you see
that what a bit of sad news James Lipton
you know Inside the Actors Studio huh he
passed away today Katie yeah oh no he
said no he was 93 years old oh [ __ ] he
was your souls you know he was 93 years
older did I thought I tales from the
crib I don't think is that all exactly
how old he was
he was great interviewer great teacher -
at the school I think he was an acting
teacher they said yeah Wow yeah he was a
veteran TV writer - OH 93 years old me I
knew he was older I had no idea is that
old Wow is it on again fantastic those
glasses are crooked there whatever I
just yet
okay john c reilly this has been going
viral right now cuz Johnny Raleigh's son
is actually a model check this out
that's his son oh my
superpeople just found out that he looks
this good and they're wondering how
that's possible good looking that's the
same eyes as his dad and lips that's his
wife oh they're so cute
that's why oh let me see his wife I'm
just watch white but she this looks like
her face looks more like the Sun yes
Middle Easterners she almost looks like
she could be Indian her middle son looks
like her for sure but them together made
that guy he's a musician too do you play
30 games ik we won't be able to play the
music will give me a bride here yeah
he's a model though he was better
looking that other one yeah I mean this
is Instagram there he looks very uh
generate me look the guy from Queen no
he looks very much like it's like
Freddie Mercury like what who's who's I
don't think looks like Freddie working
now he looks more like the guy from
either by Jean who was they as a
good-looking dude who's the guy come on
who's the guy who played them
give me the movie for god sake it was it
was a [ __ ] hilarious movie and Borat
yeah yeah he's a good-looking dude for
sure very poor at some of the pictures I
saw by shauna he's a good-looking dude
it's just crazy as dead you know
that's cool good for him that's crazy it
is pretty crazy friends is gonna have a
reunion with all the entire cast I don't
know either you do this man I don't know
if it's gonna be I think is just one
show or something like that they're
doing it for Saved by the Bell - they're
doing a lot of these revenge screech in
it
yes everyone except for the one girl
loves a turtle there are one black girl
yeah she was crying about it and I think
a doctor felt why she does wanted to go
on it no she odd they didn't ask her to
be on the show Lisa yeah the guys like
did she do porn or something no I
thought is that screech speech it's good
that you got arrested you just do that
Warren
yeah just does stand-up he says well he
also did for what you just stand up like
Charlie Sheen did stand up uh what's the
name Jason diamond or something
no II is it yet doesn't then he wrote a
book saying I like how ants said they're
like [ __ ] and doing all these drugs no
wow I'm out okay dude congrats he's so
attitude well he's just lost he's tryna
make money but I can't believe click on
screech that thing I'm just but why did
uh Lisa turtle had something going on
whether I forget I think he released his
sex tape that's what he did she fast for
niche you want to see this never
stressed whoa boy keep gone what that's
like VHS it's old got that poor girl huh
yeah wasn't a good one either so it was
a real porn though that was shot and was
Hylian it though yeah he did it alright
well there's at least a turtle bottom
right Colin Farrell say Steve you had
one too no that looks like enough I
think so we just rate watching pool I
know we're just watching porn now Oh
what else we got oh I thought Lisa
totally gets really quiet for all the
watching I think she might have been out
drugs I forget I'm just surprised that
they would have yelled I'm a dog but
they wouldn't have her on I think I'm
good I don't need to see these people
play like out me see Lady Bird and Magic
Johnson play basketball 101 at 60 years
old I'm good man yeah I just leave it
you know we don't need to bring him back
I agree
public enemy fires Flavor Flav after his
feet of Herbert really came out today
that were they still that's what I'm so
super surprised that they were still
together they were not look enemy for a
while dude help up all the way my boy
Pete dropped out what did you put huge
he's all the race said [ __ ] this I could
have choked up [ __ ] this noise America
is not ready for a game error and your
husband together
there's too much for America
maybe feels really big and strong all of
us yeah maybe if he was big and like
like macho I don't notice and his
boyfriend was super feminine but
Americans can't I don't think they're
right for any of those no obviously not
no your boy Bernie's gonna be don't you
think well I don't know if it's gonna be
five in there Bernie that's one but
bernie is a lot of like I sent you that
thing on Fareed Zakaria he still added
he's so out of touch because he's always
talking about the Scandinavian system a
Denmark and that's what socialism is
dead Norway Denmark and Sweden are are
not what they were in the 80s he's
literally working off in he's model
they're very capitalist they have high
taxes but they're more billionaires per
capita in those countries than in
America and they're very old old numbers
he's looking at the health system was in
the eighties when when Sweden and all
them went bankrupt and nothing and and
wages didn't climb for 15 years that's
why they had a revolution I went back to
the capitalist system uh-huh
so [ __ ] he's just out of his mind
that's like dude get it together he'll
if they put Bernie against Trump I I'm
losing truck get used to another four
years Trump I would imagine would you
vote for Bernie no you'd vote for Trump
no you just want both I might just let
the trouble if you don't vote yeah I
don't I can't vote for our socialist
please vote for Trump I think Bernie's
just as more dangerous well I'm just in
in his in his tax ideas and he's just
out of his mind
he has no idea here's a thought about
the fact ideas have to get passed by so
many Bernie's not doing about Bernie
Bernie is a true believer and he
believes it that free college and free
free health care and all these are moral
rights and if you deal with somebody
who's talking about moral rights like
what I like about Bernie is at least
he's an old-school liberal who believes
what he preaches
he's just as authentic as it get I just
philosophically disagree with him on a
lot of reasons so don't you think he's
more reliable more sane than Trump
though um I think he looking very bad
for the economy very bad I think he I
think he would do some you know I don't
like either one of them of course and
the problem with our system is that that
that's the choice you guys are given I
thought these delegates give me these
choices so that's
the problem we've got two bad choices i
I would vote for Mayor Bloomberg he's
worth seventy billion dollars he [ __ ]
ran New York so well I mean the dude
knows the economy he knows how to manage
he's just and what he should do but he's
just too [ __ ] Bloomberg his life
you've all charismatic Bloomberg needs
to get out because Bloomberg is gonna
take votes from by that I say that's
what's gonna happen so if you want if he
if you don't want Bernie to be the
candidate for the Democrats to get out
Bloomberg could win if he just got out
of his own way he's just not charismatic
but he could look at he could look at
you know he gave a billion dollars to
charity more he's given over he's given
some crazy amount for real like this so
more than able and and but still he's
very generous with his money and what he
could do is look at Trump and go I've
given more to charity than you've ever
made in your life he could [ __ ] with
Trump like that I mean he's just so
boring
that's the problems nothing Donal that's
the problem he's just not you know let's
see him let's see what he says here I
won't see how charismatic is skill one
attempt be honest you guys watch let's
see let's refresh this and that you've
heard by now he called AIPAC a racist
platform well let me tell you he's dead
wrong even that the letter did have fake
god alright well
[Music]
it's just not terribly good
[Music]
like I just can't stand any of the
politicians oh I guess this it's a job
that you have to do I don't know I don't
know man we'll see what else we got
you want to end it on the new Easy's
[ __ ] you haven't seen these yet they're
so terrible oh my god kind of off the
Todd you trade right now since you got
so religious and look it's leather pants
whoa those Easy's are terrible
they look like growth sized feet uh-huh
uh-huh
yeah just not into it all right all
right I'm getting ready for my Crocs
whoo what I'm gonna wear Crocs on this
one say cuz it's a free country
I'm gonna stand up to last for two
months later I'm wearing yeah I know
I've been off the adidas why he trained
why yeah he's just a little too crazy I
don't like the way they're going I don't
know where those well he's sober now was
that he's not it was he emerges as
religious as he's never he's hasn't
always been religious he has his prayer
I think yes religion have you been rude
invited to that to the the Sunday
service yeah I service no somebody else
we know has run I run by it you do yeah
or you see it that's right my necklace
oh let's hear it all the time really
yeah not for me I'm all set again it was
lost there you know yeah are you doing
I'm all wearing Yeezys and they were in
is like clothes really that's a bunch of
[ __ ] faces man he's got his girl he's
got the biggest ego on the planet holy
[ __ ] I'll do know they're they think
they're trying to say it's for God its I
can't be around it
I can't what are you around my kids
wearing all this right now you're out
here right they rope off this area this
private land you came in with a
helicopter what are you doing it's all
fake I know I just met this it is I
agree with it it's music is less CDs
[ __ ] trash
was it not trash some people liked it
yeah is it exhausting guy yeah I'm in
Atlanta March 13th
Atlanta Buckhead a renounce its stadium
Buckhead arena
I'm sorry Buckhead theatre Atlanta one
night only marched her teeth then I'm
New Orleans Dark Arts New Orleans arts
14th and then just announced entire
weekend Austin Texas cap city's March
19th through the 21st that's my birthday
weekend so you know we get wild but one
weekend Wow
this Wednesday come out to the Laugh
Factory for me Brenda job Chris D'Elia
Andrew Santino Bobby Lee it's gonna be a
ridiculous show maybe even Bert
Kreischer I was talking to him so we got
it we got a crazy lineup Kansas City
Kansas City improv April 3rd and 4th
come see me April 17th and 18th I'm at
the Columbus funnybone Columbus Ohio
funny bone and then April 23rd and 25th
23rd 24th 25th I'm at the comedy zone in
Charlotte North Carolina
that's good Club yeah I'm excited come
see me come one come all to fat Cade
comfort tickets and fiery kid merch the
new merch we're event read we revamped
the merch but the store will be launched
in March six for that ass with some
tartan tartan Church stick boy hoodies
thick boy shirts we got it all that's
the old site chin so please don't go to
that but thank you all right thank you
that's the fire kid route yeah